[Applause]
bread Freedom a government for the
people as Iraq's new prime minister
begins forming his government a group of
smaller political parties with no armed
Wings Communists and reformists young
and old men and women met in Baghdad
calling themselves the forces for
Democratic change
they want officials to stop bickering
and get to work
we want those who govern to feel the
suffering of the people Iraqi blood has
become so cheap we have lost our
National Treasures our waters are gone
dry there is widespread unemployment and
suffering in the past Iraq was a
top-ranking country now we're at the
bottom of the list
Decades of decline in Iraq some say has
happened at the hands of people in power
who came out of nowhere
to political Islamic forces to those in
power to extremists with a sheer Sunni
occurred we say you've ruined Iraq you
stole it you destroyed it they came on
the back of American tanks and are loyal
to intelligence agencies of countries
like Iran Saudi Arabia and so on all of
them have Iraqi blood on their hands and
have stolen public wealth all of them
are corrupt the consensus here replace
old faces with new ones Iraq's future is
secular and the best government's focus
on the common good
yeah we don't want a symbolic government
that sits there doing nothing we want a
government that takes action creates
jobs fights poverty develops Services
repaves roads looks after the
Agriculture and private sectors
the message from Iraqis in this room is
a simple one if you are tired of status
for politics in the country then they
are the alternative and the Old Guard
political players that are dominating
the national conversation right now are
not the only ones on the political stage
dialogue not division unity and love
children are the future it's the kind of
idealism that may seem out of place in
Iraq's political landscape but Iraqis
hearsay that is exactly what their
country needs
bucked out